back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
you know you know I make the ass dude is
in Europe how things go dude huh how'd
it go in your app it's a weird deal were
you I get weird D and stood firm it's
like dude I can't believe you do a
podcast with Alanis Morissette dude this
is crazy
they said they said good luck fall on
her man we don't know about her singing
but her set was fantastic I was like wad
let's see oh come on dude she sing uh
does she sing that one song how's it go
the bill okay hey isn't it ironic you
think it's like no no Jules the one with
the tits a lasts more sets one that
looks like you yeah everyone you're
uptight your Alanis Morissette really
they're like she's funny as [ __ ] dude
good luck fall on that I'm like dude
that steel Vaughn yeah and then how'd
your cheeks do out there a lot of people
like damn deal got that [ __ ] junk in
the trunk I'm like I've been telling you
guys for a hot second he hides those
cheats bro tell him for a [ __ ] full
warm minute bro I got that J in the Trey
get them to HoneyBaked hey I got that
fricking London be royal son hell yeah
I'm talking about a little crumpet on
them cheeks did you but they don't like
juicy asses and you're up dude huh
they don't like juicy the ass is out
there I'm surprised you can get some
work getting you've been there do I've
been there several times really ups from
there dude
I'm surprised buddy's mom is from there
dude it's Europe well yours well
everybody's family's from Europe dude
well maybe originally no everyone's
really everyone's from Middle East if
you want to go way way back
not really dude you will not catch me
being from the dang all I wanted to ask
you because your juicy ass and you're up
yeah because it's frowned upon there did
you even think about getting some
surgery and Amsterdam cuz cheap now is
it really yeah yeah sticking down but
sucked it right out dude oh yeah I don't
want that would they do do you get to
take it with you you know they can put
it in other parts oh I get a little bit
of that get a little bit of ass in my
knee you know do you have fun no run I
didn't hear from you much yeah dude I
didn't hear from myself much bro
basically it's winter over there so it's
not winter it's like nighttime so it's
just like being an in the night
time for like two weeks almost that
stuff so but yeah it was good man it was
uh heard they went crazy for you man no
we had a blast they figured I was
actually you and I lent us more set they
were corrupt there yes back is that us
no her isn't her song it's like Jay Leno
she's the one that almost blew Jay Leno
in that movie theater oh that's more sad
yeah no yes I think so I know it's
people Herman did no no no that is uh
true JLo ain't getting down no movie the
theater don't listen to any of your
ideas dude sorry dude you came back from
Europe you think J Lo's getting blown by
lettuce more set in movie theaters they
call it mind your brain you look like a
[ __ ] Cinnabon that repeated third
grade bro
[Laughter]
molested molester jams real quick it
took a little off the top and it took a
little off the bottom always focus more
on the bottom you know okay punch it up
for you dude yeah a little rusty from
Europe bro
the last you punched up give you see
brother waiting for you though a lot of
you were asking about you they were
asking my Bobby Lee
good luck him Bobby Lee over there yeah
over there in April and May but I said
Bob Bobby travels over three hours he's
like John Madden of Comedy
you only take buses everywhere yeah he's
like one of those like unique animals
have to put to sleep to move it yeah
let's us again slingshot him over there
like it's locked it ain't happenin dude
you forget about Australia too man yeah
yeah that's a good point dude Bobby's
definitely more that sleeping guy do you
have fun over the dough man how's the
food
they don't seem too excited do nothing
come back bro it was just way was a lot
of like there was no it wasn't a
vacation you know you know it wasn't
like I was it I wasn't like in a gondola
on the freakin Rhine River I wasn't like
you know there was no I wasn't at
Buckingham Palace like you didn't see
the family jewels
no I didn't see the family jewels dude I
mean I masturbated twice you know but I
didn't do anything extracurricular you
know re Manas was with me he went to is
doing all the sex tourism you know yeah
we should have had him in there today
he's excited about that the dark the
dark web yeah he was on the dark yeah
I'm a European dark web do that's dark
well yeah it's a machine hostel yeah
it's like an amazing documentary bro is
it yeah is it really I think so I think
I saw the second one oof yeah it's
crispy out there man stay away from that
[ __ ] web yeah oh yeah he's on the dark
web said that so yeah what else I'm time
man feels like in it don't you forget
you're doing so much [ __ ] you for like
vs me we wouldn't do it dude we don't
see each other 105 leaks and what do you
been doing man I fired my business
manager cuz I finally can't count
you had the rest of us hire them to a
couple months before so hey we all
learned the hard way
Billy's investing punky here's got hey
Billy is invest in Ponzi schemes in
Reebok Noori box coming up now BK nights
could be a hit right you right uh yeah
man it was good bright I mean it was
just dude who is this like it just yeah
it was just crazy to see everybody from
just different places you know
gong-gong Bulls Bulls you know just
people with different accents you know
you feel good no way out Vikings people
had men that had their hair braided in
big long double braid like some man
Vikings you may like real Vikings dude I
mean a guy's shook his arm and a bunch
of [ __ ] snow fell off of it real
Vikings they all carry axes ah not in
the not in the venue what did I had them
parked outside that make sense is that
the same place where they lay
and the girls are just blonde [ __ ]
dude that's Hamburg Germany brah
did you go there - no not in it I wish I
were gonna hurt Hamburg I wish I would
have gone to Copenhagen would you wish
you took more time yeah that's he though
I went out there I think three year Jim
when we got there three years ago nobody
remembered they said you hadn't come
about three years yeah all sort of shell
[ __ ] went to me just my chin no opener
Jim would get on the right go ladies and
gentlemen I've come to stop doing this
he go ladies and gentlemen you're the
man you came to see he's my boss
Brendan job yeah crowds like this but
here's the problem I want to say I mean
you've been torn way long means I don't
want to give you an advice oh yeah we
take any yeah that makes sense
you seem like you're doing hey you seem
happy so don't take any advice well no
but doing well yeah we rush things so I
didn't see anything but how long have
you been in Iraq I get we rushed it I
didn't see anything dude there's a show
Joe Joe Joe yeah playing like the [ __ ]
dude
I'd see anything I saw the inside of
theaters and green rooms yeah and then
shook people's hand that's it yeah yeah
but but how long were you guys there
when you win not long it felt like a
month yeah it might have been like three
weeks could have been at you in there
three weeks the whole tour just we're
three weeks dude that Chinese month you
feel matter how's that CT Chen Jesus
Christ dude yeah Chen te they call it no
I was there for 17 days but yeah it was
like um yeah it was just theater to the
place to like you know sometimes you get
up and go walk around the town for a
little bit and then that was it there
just wasn't I mean I've been to Europe
before to see some stuff but it wasn't
like a vacation that make sense doing
work dude what a lot of gray now man I
missed you oh thanks man I seen you nice
taxi respond back it's whatever is it
true I think it might not have come
overseas man cricket like cricket
doesn't work over in Europe they prevent
a lot of uh you know there's a lot of
like sex trafficking
that's that dark you know I should have
tax re cuz he gets done oh he gets it
all dude he's got his VPN open he's got
his browser he's got a helm
that's picking up [ __ ] is that
blackberry oh he's got the rule
he's got the super blackberry dude what
a black kiss babe yeah one point it was
just Chappelle lacy to say it numbers
Cornell lacy with an iPad
that's his black man he won't shut up
seeing Greendale this [ __ ] do
Chappelle man he's like rodney king of
the hill dude yes country but he grew up
very 180 to flow to his vein that is a
country 2000 confusing yes this is my
last resort tattooed on his back yeah
they keep somebody as good Matt talk
who's a Cheerilee
hey were excited to like Sen Bobby Lee
Manson Bobby tell him we warned him with
trimer
well coming up we're coming to see
Brendan next month man were coming to
see Brendan next month so yeah people
were excited bright it was just wild to
see like just different people be
excited they had yeah British peep how
was laughing so hard I mean calendar and
Stewie laughing zowie posted re bombed
some material won't work out some
material
he came back to this [ __ ] sweat his
Faizal do I know you're listening here -
turn it off yeah I said at least you get
the bomb and go to a nice hotel do a now
who's coming up you had a bomb and I
can't just go sleep under your own hand
[Laughter]
different time bro yeah it was great I
mean just here you got to hear there
were people like just like homeless
people different countries you know
they'd be like I'm homeless
not with that cute accent that cutie
little accent nobody yeah yeah yeah let
me buy you a couple chocolates my big
thing is giving chocolate to the
homeless bro
what kind of chocolate you giving out
milk chocolate I don't go anything hi
you don't go dark you don't do the 80%
cocoa I feel like it back to enough yeah
but you don't want them thinking about
drugs like oh I got 80% cocoa
you know I got 10% angel dust let me see
what I can makes up see what as I'm
about to [ __ ] yeah I'm about to get
Nestle Quik up in this but we're back
dude we are
backstreet's back alright the bros are
back in town yeah there you go
dude new studios looking pretty tasty
y'all it's bad bro
dude the studio looking does this game
up tasty huh cut my animal could be a
little bit of dried skeet Brody it is uh
naked chicken in here so oh my yeah I
was up all night that's how I stayed up
all night
yeah damn it worked it on this yeah
really cuz you had five weeks
I work on deadlines okay been here about
five well they were a real be in a real
rat whenever we started so yeah had to
get him killed yet to get him to iron
him out lot went on brother drop a lot
of honey do we're back we're back baby
2020 we're getting all dude
yeah we are man oh it's getting old
well thanks for having me man wow it's
your world man I'm just living in a dude
well I'm just happy to be here man thank
you for having me well thanks thanks for
allowing me to have a hit yeah
hey not allowing you you were having me
or how to get here okay man what's good
to see you what I'm saying hey did you
play quarterback for Aaron Hernandez in
high school huh
what now I don't know random question
well I just popped in my head I don't
know did you guys see the Aron thing did
you see it yeah I didn't like the part
at the end they tried to make him seem
like a gay man I feel like they kind of
squeeze that inner force of a gay thing
and I didn't trust the young dude who
said that he might have been gay oh dude
that came out that guy's full of [ __ ]
yeah cuz the real dude came out was like
the kid even play quarterback yeah get
full of [ __ ] yeah yeah him and the dad
were full of [ __ ] that was the dad too
yeah they were both ready to like
because they're like dropping like gems
like if everything was prepared and they
had like one line or the [ __ ] is
happening right now yeah yeah you did
their grade was that [ __ ] straight
Canole hustler TV had a big mouth on him
you see yeah he did big bring him a
picture of the dead do you mind real
quick he spoke well too and the kid was
blind his ass off he's like man me and
Aaron you know we get doing practice we
just go to his room I suck them off I'm
like [ __ ] I'm not that's not that's not
the way people talk did he say yeah man
I didn't hear that part I listened to
the whole thing really out there uncut
version yeah man he must there's a dad
up a little more there's that up a
little more right there to the right
right there father the guy to experiment
with Aaron too much that's undefeated
dude yeah that looks like Joey don't ask
if you look ahead him dude it looks very
strange dude get you a girl who's as
loyal Xin Hernandez girl yeah this guy
looks like Joey diazepam right here look
he looks like Joey Diaz and Sam Tripoli
had a baby his girl down you know I'm
having guns and [ __ ] yeah
yeah but come on not shocked about that
really yeah dude he murdered her
sister's boyfriend and she still sat
next to him you know ganks that if
somebody marry murders my sister's
boyfriend dude you celebrate oh no I'm
gonna hide a gun for like yeah somebody
else already got murder dude I'm gonna
do whatever needs to be done to not get
murdered that's true yeah I'm knocking
like no way buster [ __ ] murder oh you
could just go to the cop if you wanna be
a straight [ __ ] me that's true she was
[ __ ] down though man
she's even even at the very end but she
was the baby mama she had to be
he didn't have much else going on dude I
mean at that point your analogies
already cashed out with the [ __ ] body
eggs she's got the baby from the man
what is she gonna do dude his CT was so
bad that [ __ ]
they told him he's getting life and
every time they talk to me I can't wait
to get out of here man yeah a few days
she was like the [ __ ] are you talking
yeah I'll be out in an hour
yeah Swain for my paper yeah it's like
well I make it to see WrestleMania yeah
like I didn't kill Nicole Brown right
don't tell Brady I'll be there Sunday
don't have to worry dude the diamond in
season he's the only one running out
routes in the shower dude yeah man it's
a wild it seemed like he was just I
don't know like he just did in did you
feel bad for him good question I did I
felt well the doctor here's the thing
about documentaries it focuses so much
sometimes on one person to give you so
much of their story that I think as a
human you can't help but feel sorry for
them because you
learning so much about them but you if
they too focused more on the boy you
know the odontoid they got killed not
they might have made you feel it might
make you feel more for him yeah it could
be another documentary that's just about
him and you're like oh it makes ya makes
him seem like a monster but also like
that Odin Lloyd they said he was
murdered because he knew about Aaron
being gay really yeah he wore the head
he was he was gonna he was gonna out him
really so he was like ooh I'm gonna kill
you but losing an out of two who even
would have believed that just that high
school quarterback told y'all yeah it's
right it's just that you know what it is
is the tragic story just like dad yeah
you know you was battling Gronk he was
an amazing player you're not better than
Gronk dude he's more town feeling drunk
for sure hmm no he wasn't
so yeah took me a long time to think
about that one like the kind of guy who
works at a concession stand but he says
it's closed so we can have all the
snacks inside
dude it's 7:00 a.m. sorry fresh out
yes it's closed but you listed in there
and you just hear a bunch of [ __ ]
music going on and somebody just having
them having a bunch of hot dogs smoking
in the boys room yeah
I wish man hey we're on a monster you
like what do you mean you're close I
know we sent chin on this date I can be
more excited about it
ibid even asked I didn't even ask I
don't even look on social media I don't
wanna know how it went
nothing I've been saving it just for
this well I saw one picture of chin like
feeding her and I was a grill just alive
well that's a bite that I don't get
that's your thinking I'm bad there's 40
carbs for daddy that are going astray
[Laughter]
Nick what do we have what do we do for
chin get us into this world uh they went
out on isn't Derek and Lee wanna do it
he's got the video all right go bro you
know what's up Dee oh this video I
haven't put the video together do we
need to ask any question before we go
this we should we watch this first I
think we watch this little sizzle reel
and then we'll get the recap from chin
and then we can FaceTime Carly later and
see what dude that's the worst name for
a girl that's not it you know she liked
it yeah did you call hot girl chin at
all during the day I called her Tina
that's beautiful man Tito
yeah Tito so obviously Gina's a little
bit of that Aaron Hernandez Nathan women
men and still trying to hook up with
nobody well that's a gateway drug yeah
Thank You Oliver
yeah let's call chintz quarterback in
high school I'm right now just kidding
this is the first date this is the first
gender date right wait real quick Kat
were you there yes I was were you there
Dean I was with you at San Jose
okay ICG Nick yep and so was our
videographer Mike now who really hooked
it up we we threw together basically an
episode of blind date with a three-man
team
I've seen a lot of blind date so hey do
you or do you mean blind date or To
Catch a Predator all right well I don't
trust Cheney they're under you guys to
talk now right now but I also do not
trust or chinnese as they call them
well my plan for tonight was to do what
a typical free night is right so usually
if you go we'd grab drinks get Korean
barbecue grab dessert which is usually
boba if you're Asian you know exactly
what I'm talking about
and I think mo bar that I love that want
her to try and then afterwards small of
them could all be okie studio and get
even more drinks yes and then let me do
what I think I do best
yeah yeah I'm saying I think you might
know this but it's been a while I'm
gonna be honest in cat I've never in my
life ever been on a date with what we
would call her and me Chang a white girl
that's the N word for white girl in LA
hey also known as a cracker where I come
from how dare you Jim Wow someone of
another race for you no I'm not I don't
really know it's more just like another
day just better ribs at her bro you do
not put your pants on here break up that
little big
what are we sit on their bare that idea
you'd be farting chin dumb percentage is
an old person drinking having fun dude
with you hit the elbow here he said more
room he said let's tighten up her who
achieves nice on the grill June did you
do it they just not make her cook that
chip
okay second a to the ninth date second
date to life keeping cookin
damn [ __ ] under that meat boy hey bro
that sizzler hater
Oh Richard it's juicy boy Amon I should
juicy grabbing at West
[Music]
host date with cat here we go you know
what it looked better than I thought it
would be - dude that's why I've never
dated an asian man or any man for that
matter we saw that and you leave me
alone so now do we do
does it go to like chinder after dark is
that it we never sizzle reel just for
you guys to watch in studio because we
thought to watch the whole thing it'd be
a bit much but we've got like a
12-minute thing that's gonna drop the
same time this episode does that you see
a little bit more of their conversation
but but Korean barbecue was the entire
date so that was it and then we also
have a little exit interviewing chin
here that might be the highlight yeah
all right I'm gonna be honest I didn't
think I would like her that much she's
white but she's actually pretty [ __ ]
cool yeah very funny and sweet and nice
and we got along pretty well it's gonna
sound really bad but she's we sat next
to each other all right and every time
we would take shots together her tits
are good my speaker and as soon as I
would take a shot I would see it and
they were just well would look to see
you do it jiggle well we like it was we
lost
well [ __ ] you know you lot we we've
been winning the entire game and you
threw [ __ ] the only way
I'm on it because today I'll supposed to
go karaoke with her too
and then I think it was just so perfect
that we should just leave this alone and
then do a second date with karaoke and
then also I hope she wears something low
top because good job Kat that's nice you
know you you're winning off all three
quarters we got in the fourth you know
panic dude I know honestly why didn't ya
why didn't things escalate cuz it seemed
like you guys had a nice time at the
dinner y'all was doing the meat and
everything somebody had you had two or
three types of meat out there's on the
wobbly pop she's laughing wobbly for
sure yeah so why not take it to karaoke
and we get that night vision out uh very
oaky where you guys get bear hair yeah I
mean if we went to karaoke
I know first of all ending it that way
was probably perfect like you know oh
yeah you're at a peak of like it's
awesome in it there and then if I will
karaoke I know what I could do there
yeah and then stuff can happen after
that
yeah those sweater puppies I'm not gonna
have you guys filming her after karaoke
yeah dude I mean you could film that on
your own yeah you could do something
yeah we could do a drawing of it I would
do it for you yeah dinner was two hours
and 20 minutes to like they just KITT we
uh cat Mike and I all ate Korean
barbecue at the same time and we were
done like an hour in and they just kept
had food and drinks coming out like they
had a blast and after the date Carly
just kept saying I'm down for anything
I'm down for anything but she wasn't
down for Chinni thing bro yeah she was
yes she was gonna fumble fumble dude
he's dressed like George Michael did a
funeral of course he fumbled dude he
looks like somebody that plays a
keyboard in a lotta edit on a late night
television bro chin is one step away
from a deaf guy
- of course he fumbled it was great hot
part was so down dude and your
superpower singing you didn't get there
but no but yeah I think you played a
smart move be good be gone that's the
move you do well you do and you get out
you were there cat you were on the front
lines
what was the female perspective of this
uh of this little Vietnam
nom-nom-nom-nom because they ate for two
hours
hey who paid for this thing we pay only
we did did we later yeah okay it was
good chin was killing it in the
beginning and we lost energy right no it
wasn't that it was she's gonna talk a
little too much energy towards the end
in the post interview like you said but
to be fair she also was very tipsy she
was down to have like not just a good
night but maybe like a good morning if
their they went to carry a girl what she
was wrong cause the bad interview with
her yeah we had a part of it in that
clip back [ __ ] that'll be in the longer
thing on YouTube you can check it out on
yeah and we can talk to her we can go
straight to her face timer we can't work
I was recovering from the GHB meet that
chin was serving over there dude okay
from that [ __ ] beef teriyaki dipped
in nyquil chin out over there everything
be scary yeah I did
so right this tastes familiar this
nyquil that be very sleepy chin with
servitude melatonin chicken are Bill
Cosby [ __ ] skewers baby then be Cosby
threader's over there
well enough because me falafels baby on
a pillow of rice dude a huge pillow of
rice yeah they still on a bed uh what
are we gonna talk to about first let's
just don't call her blindly dude listen
yeah you suck with women yeah you have
to get a laugh for last time bill do you
like TV
oh yeah cuz I want to be prepared okay
we just saw what happens when you don't
prepare and go out with somebody I know
you talk about her tits god dammit Jim I
thought it'd be real cute chills like
yeah I was thinking the whole time is
yeah as soon as you a dude cheers me a
[ __ ] we get squeezed together in my
mouth now what's all the real chin came
out chant shady um yes so what are we
gonna talk to her about chopsticks if we
gonna say how was the evening okay well
here's the thing Jim would you go on a
second that's when you did you have fun
where did he mess up did you go did you
go on a date after that did you have a
friend pick you up from there did you go
do some other karaoke Wow yes you might
have maybe she hadn't ladies like him or
she was like I was down for more and
then gin just took off talking about you
know some [ __ ] the head to go do
sing in his bedroom so I had my friend
pick me up yeah we sent her in an uber
home and it was going to the address she
gave she was originally picked up at but
she asked to take a detour and she ended
up going to Newport Beach she party more
that night you know really yeah yeah
good Wow let's see how this might adjust
really kids adjacent care to get nasty
might have had an assist bro let's see
what we got right here Bob City
you feel me it's Lob City over there bro
I tell you what I'm on right now man can
I tell you my problem before you tell me
yours try to tell my problem okay I
can't get enough greens man I think I
take spinach I well I think broccoli and
it's just it's so much work it sounds
like it man it's not how you do it and
you got a boiler
now just I don't know man do you or you
you know what you need man athletic
greens bro what are you talking about
you think I'm talking about aliens that
do track and field you know dude I'm
talking about athletic greens
it's the ultimate daily all-in-one
health drink it has 75 items minor roles
and whole sourced ingredients that make
it easier for you to get comprehensive
nutrition without the need for pills
powders and complex routines man Wow
it's the most complete supplement for a
better you Wow no capsules well I take
it every morning you mix it in you throw
a little deal that comes in this nice
little daily deal one scoop of athletic
greens provides convenient a for blonds
tasty solution to fill the gaps in your
diet I'm gonna die right now you know me
I struggle with my weight dude I'm sick
oh I stay thick definitely yeah I'll
drink gravy if you leave it out dude if
I think now on my left foot eat greens
every time I walk by you I hear of and I
hear it of it yes bingo I got your ham
the biscuits are done and Cinnabon
toasty bro not anymore broke joke's on
you cuz I take athletic greens all right
yeah a rest start every day with
athletic greens like I've been fooling
you the whole time
I think my energies through the roof
well I think I think I'm never sick my
gut health is fantastic oh yeah that's
probably why cuz of athletic greens no
joke athletic greens I take it every day
I'm getting my mother some as a gift
it's gluten-free it's dairy-free
it's vegan friendly no harmful chemicals
no pesticides so if you got worms or
something like that
bro you still can keep them bro it's not
gonna kill them man give them a deal how
about that how about that you won't be
healthy when I help your lifestyle maybe
a nap I don't allege him I got the deal
for you give them that and let it
greens.com /k ats get the cats get the
cat get the cats and claim my special
offer today 20 free travel packs valued
at $79 with your first purchase
that's athletic greens dot-com /k ats
get the casket the cat get the brand-new
look we hate to interrupt it but
something has to be done man I'm sick of
this bush dude I have a giant bush like
a semi think you talk about the 94
election
oh you talk about George Bush
this bush yeah oh dude yeah rah you got
that it looks like George Bush is never
an afro it's the thing you got that
George Clinton growing around your junk
dude
not anymore bro because there's a new
trimmer just released moments ago yeah
I've talked about the lawnmower 3.0
manscaping trimmer it's available for
purchase right now yep this
third-generation manscape trimmer
features a cutting-edge serum ik blade
to prevent manscaping accidents so many
people out there dude a lot of times if
you put your ear out of a car window you
could hear somebody Nick they're nuts
over 70 miles away yeah I'm talking
about a real proper premium nut cutter a
mean premium the battery will last up to
90 minutes we're gonna take that long
but you never know dude but how
beautiful is it to be cut from in around
your friggin junk 490 do you're like
Pablo prick Casso at that point do you
tightening up that frickin body blade
yeah tighten it up and get 20% off and
free shipping with the code Kay 80s at
manscape calm and as always your balls
will thank you yep and 20% off and free
shipping with the code Kay 80s at
manscape calm that's 20% off with free
shipping manscape commies code cats and
one of the coolest new features that
they have is the LED light so you can
groom your crotch and with dark comes
your hand I do it like the bats to get
risk you do like Bear Grylls but I do it
like the Owls yeah maybe she's at work
she got out of a meeting at 11:50 she's
a girl
how you doing you're so cool is she are
you hungover right now no she looks nice
it's not hungover no I think she looks
nice she could also be hungover as well
can't be drinking at work we just saw
the date think that first of all thank
you for going with chin yeah you're good
sport yeah it seemed like you guys had a
lot of chemistry
yes and liquor
and beef yeah what what did you enjoy
about the evening honestly it was really
it was an easy date hangout thing it
wasn't I don't know it's not it wasn't
weird I thought it might be because well
I mean like I didn't really know too
much about your guys like podcast and
who you guys are until my friend sent me
in and so I was reading people's
comments on like YouTube and Instagram
me stuff and so I was like why is their
own coaling is kind like a murderer
don't read YouTube comments girl that's
not gonna help you guys I can get guy
talk but then so like okay whatever and
then when he attacks me like two days
before they go this guy seems really
normal so I was like nervous going into
it and I'm a pretty social person so I
wasn't really afraid it was kind of just
normal it seemed like you guys had a
really nice time it seemed like
everybody had a really nice time it went
way better than we thought I gotta be
honest we thought you're gonna show up
with bodyguards smart is that your first
time is that your first time getting
Korean barbecue it was my second yeah I
knew it
but for I'm not that big of a fan but
and now we also had a question for you
so it seemed like you're having a great
time afterwards and and maybe you guys
we're gonna do karaoke then she was like
I gotta go and took off and then did you
what did you do after dinner like they
were like one of my best friend this
girl isn't something you guys so we went
and I'm
they're out why not
and then I tell you about the day what
did you tell him what was your first
response to them was really fun it was
normal I did tell them oh it's funny
only to like pre-imposed
interviews and stuff and they were just
dying at it they thought it was the
funniest thing had you ever and this was
the first time you'd ever been out with
a Mongol right right it's a legit
question then Genghis Khan vibes you
know I look I think it's brave you know
some people are brave or afraid of data
you know just date somebody that's any
different than them especially somebody
that's from not only from Asia but from
outer space like our unique man chin
here but no it seemed like you guys had
a great time he was curious I mean I'll
let him ask you but this just me kind of
I guess Haskin form would you be down to
do a second date some karaoke cuz that's
where he really shines like a ton of
research but I know like he can sing as
having them before he encounters like oh
yeah I know he's like really good
mouthing okay [ __ ] yeah well what's
something that you're good at like
extracurricular thing capability
oh no like I'm karaoke that's how you
use somebody to teach you probably a
little something show you the rope how
pretty is guitar karaoke and hang out
I mean romantically speaking I'm not
sure but he was really fun well hated
romantic you just not your type is it
but what is it cuz he's a big handsome
dude tall dude chicks dig them are you
really short you look tall in the video
I saw recently
just now you look tall you look tall
enough tall are you you keep talking 5/3
standard is a good height yeah anything
could happen
yeah yeah yeah you can still do stuff
nobody looks weird if you're outdoors or
anything you don't look like oh you
shouldn't be out here that's for 11 and
under people are like what's going on
where's your folks all the time you know
you're like I'm 40 what do you mean but
what points what points would you give
chin if we continue to do dates with
them what do you where does he go wrong
now is it and now is it a thing where
just cuz he's Asian maybe that's not
your flavor which is fine like I don't
like shrimp flavor in top ramens you
know no I mean I'm 25 you're 42 chin
yeah Jesus Christ you wanna have a seat
I'm so sorry Carly
yeah sending you out with one of your
dad's friend
I don't know works it out with your
dad's co-workers [ __ ] barbecue of
course should I go to like karaoke but
no but I want snacks a date with like a
Jerry Garcia
we apologize actually we got a Ouija
board here and Winston Churchill don't
you wanna date no we think that it's
great that you went I thought you were
great sport
you're perfect on the first one yeah
fantastic but but you know we'll find
sewing around his age that you like
woody what could he do better though
what do you think you could improve on
what's he missing you think see that's
Jim's prom chin says nothing and that
can't be the case you know I don't
really think I mean I can have a
conversation with a wall literally like
I'm really social so if someone can't
hold a conversation with me even make a
problem yep but he obviously really held
a conversation and he's super funny he's
nice he's normal
well there's the only I've been calling
not normal that's just kind of a joke
yeah and he knows that he isn't but so
you're just saying he just wasn't a love
connection but there was a connection
but just maybe not a love connect
there's an age gap Britain didn't she
said that kind of like a pretty big age
gap and but overall like anything else
was fine I can't believe how have you
gotten any dates since that no hmm I
mean it was Friday
it was Friday right who's this past
Friday yeah what are we in oh you're
pretty girl I know girls going on dates
every goddamn night have you some girls
gone wild those videos dude have I ever
that make sense I love your attitude
Carly thank you so much for being a part
of gender and for just helping us look
for love for our friend Thank You Carly
your great story to tell people yeah
you're great and now I'm fans of you
guys so and like I felt like a lot of my
friends are fans of you guys so now I'm
gonna look up see when you guys are like
in town and you can see like a show I
love it yeah well yeah we'll share your
on our social media on King in the stink
so that you know if there is a young man
out there that you know could be your
type you might get some creepers but
yeah but then like I tell people were
like oh my gosh it doesn't work out you
know like we'll take you out but I'm
like I can't see your profile because
it's a private you have nothing in your
bio I don't your picture is like a
cartoon oh that was Nick that was our
producer yeah that was Nick - my opener
a song
[Laughter]
I'm just checking
mixa mixa legend man it is a good guy
but no so a lot of creepers already came
here so that was a song just ignore me
yeah you're doing the damn thing thank
you for being on this you're a great
sport about it
it's not easy the best Holly good luck
out there in love okay bye Carly doing
the damn thing you both you guys I'm
proud of both you guys you guys did a
great job you guys killed that that
could have been a nightmare you killed
that yeah
you guys shot it well everything was
hearing my thing I'll see chin that's
not a match what if we open it up to
other kids 51 cheese to anyone she like
yeah I guess um but you could even we
could help a bunch people find some love
man you know bro we can barely [ __ ]
keep our [ __ ] together dude okay well we
didn't have a key to the bathroom in the
hall are you sure I hate me [ __ ] your
signs are tough so we did Chan that's a
tough sell yeah that lives in the shells
of a library Assad you'll be a name
you'd like we can only do so much
qinger thing up make a wish Islamic
psych I do this sleeps in a really old
book room your kid who looks like that
worm that crawls out of the Apple
[ __ ] gate let's see what non-gay
let's do it non gay dad says let's go to
another gay dad
let's get an on gay dad head and see
what he says oh that doesn't make it's
not a soccer but brown but he's brown
work oh that they're brown whatever we
do next time if we send chin strangers
without our not our I love the idea I
love I love Dino Ari art the liability
signs a waiver probably you know Jones
Marc Webb it better be a huge waiver
either way next time we have to have a
air pod in someone's ear and you guys
are feedback whines van yes we could we
could hear their conversation the whole
time but if we could go the other way
that's what makes him help we can help
chin or Ari out would be like you know
dude ask her you know dude pour another
shots spilled on your pants guys I have
an announcement to make to you guys that
you're married not married but cat knows
this I told Nick already are you coming
out right he told what Nick
I told me because we're filming about
the racial slurs I'm doing I'm not gonna
do like you know something crazy so I've
been dating my best friend for a little
while now it's Kat no no he's a he's a
power lifter from Fresno I'm just
kidding it's a girl you guys know you
met her before I've met her you met her
mother who's gay somebody's gate you're
brave you're brave dude I'm King I see
you're brave coming out dude
she said he had sex with Aaron Hernandez
in high school you you're really dating
so jigna cat knows have you said mederic
out where did did I meet her and uh see
the shows one of the shows that's all
i'ma say I don't wanna go to I don't
know did you meet her dad meet in San
Diego San Francisco one of those so
channel Ben Francisco we paid for two
hours of food for you in this way man
it's a great my friend Hawk Carlton have
a chance it's a great show the game she
can't win
she said the age gap is ridiculously
crazy there's no way well how's the girl
you're dating
closer to my age big man I sound like
this girl's evening I feel like we got
no need
I've had that girl from afford it in
middle school told her buddy had a
girlfriend the living of town next door
and I met her like Aaron Hernandez high
school quarterback right now let's go to
that quarterbacks dad again let's bring
up another picture that day if he
believes in my song I didn't everybody
did it everybody was eighth nerve wow
chance you're dating huh
well [ __ ] my friend hardly didn't have a
chance
yeah us you told us that Brendan but
what I'm saying is this dude next time
we're paying for two hours worth of food
and liquor okay next time you order some
[ __ ] sake bottles I think you're so
juice up the only reason I agreed to pay
for what you know who are you Darren
Sharper chill do seven balls of sake
somebody get in the game son that's
science yeah you think it's math that's
dating man they go over six bars like
well here we go
so I can't do me on gender someone else
for sure somebody well you should've
told us that before we are in $70 dolls
that before you invested a hundred grand
to the goddamn Graf exam yeah you what
this is like the bachelor the guy before
it starts going so I got married
you [ __ ] I didn't [ __ ] anyone little
[ __ ]
look here [ __ ] yeah you're going
on dates again all right please two more
days hey bro odds are on
you're dating your best friend that's a
powerlifter out of Fresno that ain't
working out oh yeah hey that's not
working out being at the dude named Greg
he'll understand dude yeah the Fresno
beer will understand the rare bear of
Fresno that Fresno Bulldog will
understand if you bother dude how to see
something hairy dude named chin Bochner
rolling out of the woods right now
you're going to hell Jen right oh I
shouldn't have said that but if that's
the way you treat people you taking
somebody had a great time
yeah yeah you're right man never mind
good time yeah I'm just saying she's
playing the games you can't win you know
yeah cat what do you feel like what do
you take away you were there you were on
the air in the foxhole yeah it was a lot
of fun and went a lot better than any of
us thought it would go the only issue is
I think we wanted chin in his element so
we went to go get Korean barbecue but it
was so hard to film there there were so
many unfriendly Korean workers who kept
telling us to put our cameras hey
standard but why your that they're
[ __ ]
oh I'm sure a lot of people want to film
in there it's just distracting for
people but also but why couldn't they be
were they if they weren't helpful like I
mean your Korean are you Korean yes okay
so were they were they Korean or were
they Chinese there might be some Chinese
women but there must be straight no [ __ ]
you're been around Chinese people they
take no [ __ ] they're so rude oh yeah
very very dangerous basically when I was
trying to get permission to film at
these places earlier in the day I was
telling him that I had a I was working
for a couple and it was their one-year
anniversary and this was their first
date spot and they didn't give a [ __ ]
shut it down yeah [ __ ] tramps trans
you mean keep my jobs but are a lot of
awesome trainer thing that's what I may
not even train you right
I'm a Tran a lot of my people yes they
are yeah
the Tran boy get on the train or get off
dude
well chin let me ask you this guy where
do we go from here yeah that's I mean
now we know but rooms getting [ __ ]
married next week we got to find someone
else someone else who wants to come on
you find somebody think about it nick
has a lady yep more official now right
you're bragging a lot this episode man
oh he's got a lady dude killing it dude
things are looking up he's trying to set
up his senior buddy is a dope rod you
got a lady yeah we busted nuts like
courtyards could you knock your girl up
you freak
oh you knocked my girl off the way
you're at it yeah keep your eyes off my
girl man I to keep the window so close
so that my girl wouldn't even get
pregnant yeah I'm now saying your ideas
are you gonna come up with
you're hopeless we don't you're a
liability we will do that on the 12-step
program that's not a first date well I'm
not even on step one third steps a doozy
why is that Shepherd cat single can I
say that count
yeah you're single yeah what's up in
trouble just didn't work out Wow God
dude you don't get to perfect
dude that would be [ __ ] my slime that
will have to help but but I think we're
in the truck and I but we're in the rain
dilemma truck okay we get a truck we get
a van you call the Kingston van we get
it.white put honey on this be shuttle no
this is a subdued the skete Sean doesn't
end well yeah yeah yeah yeah but but
we'll put what buddy and I get the
random dudes air make it work with that
oh here's a chance at with cash yeah I I
don't feel comfortable I feel like we're
st. cat up you get murdered
I think we're setting ourselves up to
definitely get in Cathy watch it
concerns let's see I am open to the idea
if I see chinder work with a couple more
people yeah we don't hit up a cat right
now it's too early
sterling well we'll see what happens
maybe we'll have somebody come in and
see if we can find them someone maybe we
put re out on the dark web re very yeah
he's great people do friends
no no he's cool he's my module I love
him like your brother
I don't trust him Jonathan I seem like a
I got this new jacket he's like yeah her
name is Belinda like our guy who will
make her we can't show the day yes did
you guys shoot three people on your date
did why did your date just cut to it the
first season of Dexter dude why'd you
guys my first round trip take us to
Hawaii
yeah and only one of you guys came back
and charged our card though uh look we
could see what happens man we could yeah
look anybody could find love so it's
possible you know we'll see what happens
something good could happen bro just
brainstorming ideas here hello hello
dude why are you still living in the
past they have to ask who it is at your
door when you can already know bro huh
just so right dude you could been a
robber yeah it could have been it could
have been a robber trying to steal all
my stuff I could have been a burgle
Larry bro you got to know what's up dude
simply safe home security it's like
getting commercial grade enterprise
level security but for your own home
being here's the thing dude outdoor
cameras and doorbells alert you to
anyone walking around your house you
want to wait oh did someone break in I'm
gonna call the cops now too late yeah
too late and really have yourself to
blame yeah everything you love is gone
yeah now I'm gonna watch first 48 yeah
it goes down have you ever watched the
last 48 dude it's at a funeral because
you didn't take care of yourself you now
simply safe simply say protect your home
from fires water damage and carbon
monoxide poisoning yeah how about entry
motion glass break sensors lot glass
break sensors good luck getting in it's
all monitored 24/7 by live security
professionals you can set up your system
yourself no tools needed and simply save
experts can do it for you if you want if
you can't figure out ready for the
it's only 50 cents a day no contracts
what's your safety worth to you yeah 57
50 cent that's a dollar every two days
that's three dollars and fit a cent a
week go to simply safe
si MP li SI fe calm /k 80s to save on
home security today
that's si m PL ah safe dot-com / cats
get the kit get the kit get the case ro
that here in the back in a little long
brother it's getting a little long
you have to worry about losing it but
here's the thing 66% of men start to
lose their hair by the age of 35 that's
why I grew my now I know it's maybe a
little bit of cinnamon I can't have this
I can't have them start growing it out
I'm starting using just just I'm gonna
start using hams and then what it's get
this thick man bra you look beautiful
man they've really come a long way when
I met you wasn't as good looking and not
you better looking than you were my hair
brown I Razor Ramon thanks to four hems
comm one-stop shop for hair loss skin
care central one is for the bros oh yeah
look sexual wellness if anybody knows
about being sexually on well it's boy
okay you know what I'm sayin bruh I'll
bring in her an erection to a [ __ ]
crafts in a arts and crafts environment
yeah it's just not proper yeah there's
nothing better all right no snake oil
pills or gas station counter so I'm
sorry real stuff prescription solutions
backed by science yeah you don't buy
that stuff over to gas station you you
know you're getting a couple quarts of
diesel in one of them Rhino hitters at
the gas yeah you don't want that yeah
one of those you got to have that
erection later all over trying to get
pump and dude yeah don't get right
listen no more awkward in-person doctor
visits or long pharmacy lines forget all
that
get your body right get your dick right
son quit living like a [ __ ] little
inchworm bro and show up with that snake
to your stepmothers freaking funeral bro
that's 2020 hit that Rooter out
you show up with a real root bro yeah
three month minimum subscription
prescription requires an online
consultation with the physician who will
determine if the prescription is
appropriate that's easy do you your
first month free course all you have to
do is go to four hems calm slash Katie
yes yes that's four names doc time /k 80
all day every day cats for ham comp /
cats offer valid if for sky three month
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website for full details
important safety information hillary was
talking [ __ ] to Barney this morning you
guys see that so funny old piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] he said nobody likes then
did you see the other old broad talk
[ __ ] - Bernie - I just think it's great
that old people are finally fighting
with each other in public - nothing
better when old people throw fists cuz
nobody gets hurt it's like watching
women's fighting it's great I'm trying
to take your boat but all the same [ __ ]
as a girl Kat I feel like her Bloods on
my hands now a lot has happened a lot
has happened I chin I'm I'm not trying
to be funny I don't know that I can
vouch for that Jenny about well for that
okay I literally I thought children come
out right now
I have a big announcement like I don't
because Asian people are usually pretty
smart it took you 42 years and you heard
Gators be the worst [ __ ] math I've
ever ever seen this to be the probably
the worst platform to drive people know
their game when they're four or five
dude I don't know dude you don't think
oh they know they lose the dream of
being samurais I'm like out [ __ ] I'm gay
yeah and at some point you have to kill
yourself or some what do you guys have
to do Jeff if you don't date yeah or if
you want to see if you're gay or not I
don't know something I'll just cut off
your pinky if you think you're gay no
you kill yourself at your dad
order something just can't tell you you
can't tell your parents is it there a
suicide forest
yes Japan yeah Jesus Christ man crazy
right
well what do you got what else you got
you guys went to the name game real
quick sure one of the new topics yeah
let's get in one of the new topics we do
have to announce here some new topics
so let's announce those right now your
nootropics
yeah I'm saying cuz we have a special
video for one the new topics okay and I
was gonna save it for after or we can do
a mouse up to you but guard um we're
gonna get it in the name game let's do
it now do it out let's do it now the new
topic boys is Saint my ink okay you want
people to send in pictures of your
tattoos video tattoos
videos of why you know you got that
tattoo and win and how [ __ ] up you
were yeah brief videos brief video brief
you know says documentary on your
[ __ ] tattoo on your ankle yes but we
got our first submission boys and you
might recognize it iris about this I
have anxiety today you do oh so you got
the tip on this one guys just got out of
the shower - how much time obviously my
very busy man but I knew [ __ ]
segments or whatever it's called
describe your tattoo or whatever kind of
catch you think all that but anyway I
figured I'd be the first century yeah I
have tattoos and I got them right here
submit and I got these by dr. woo who
was a great artist and he did this look
at the detailing that eagle that's
because I got that tired eagle joke that
I have and the my special of Netflix man
on fire and that's for the man on fire
and that's what I got and I got them
when I was 37 because I wanted to get
them because I wanted to I want I got
them at that age because I never want to
get them when I was younger because I
thought I would regret them much like
you guys definitely regret doing this
podcast together you absolutely do I
have to do this podcast now because of
the money you're not doing it because
you want to you're doing it because of
the money and that's fine but it's a
cash crop
unlike my podcast congratulations from
the soul because it's straight from the
soul everything for an hour the whole so
guys stop listening to the king in this
thing
congratulations okay you know I you know
how you can come on over you can use
this [ __ ] plane the King in the sting
this thing in the King I don't even know
what the [ __ ] it's going to be honest
[Laughter]
first of all how did this goon yeah okay
infiltrate our airway this your buddy
Brenda you time and L first also on let
you guys know that uh this video
submission was brought to you by the
cash app because you need the money
there well look Brandon this is you and
uh this is you and Brian's [ __ ] meal
ticket so the only two people sitting on
that plate on his armor you first of all
hated tattoos didn't need remember that
he's make fun of people with tattoos and
then he gets a bro gets a little money
in the bank bout a chain like a [ __ ]
like Gucci man he got tatted up not only
to get that up but he did on his [ __ ]
arm
on his wrist where everybody can see it
and somebody said it was hiding he had
like some type of a skin disorder or
something that it was hiding which is
something that I heard but I also could
have made that up kill him will use a
little just for men on that beard either
no I'm saying maybe someone brush in
yeah we do anything nothing too heavy
yeah I wouldn't go real dark you know
that was so [ __ ] fun thank my Inc
dude how do you do it why does that on
his arm so we could easily sink it if it
was flight TWA 564 or whatever when that
one is what about you guys over in
Vietnam you guys are taking now planes
like nothing left and right yeah you
guys are line
huh your ears are hiding them huh yeah
no you flying over Iraq that's and he's
gonna take down and blame it on somebody
else am i right yeah look at this dude
think my ink Russ is it there it's think
it speakers heat sink it Brendon I'll
give them this I'll give this that dr.
Wu is amazing [ __ ] it was any good bro
who ain't good dude it's drawing all of
it looks like third semester [ __ ]
heart bro how did you get out of New
Orleans without any tattoos man with the
[ __ ] you've been through I have one
tattoo dude now never show it to you
really it's on your ass in it no you
creep where's the back huh I'm not
telling how this told y'all wasn't
telling you would you you think I'm
gonna forget that in just a second yeah
no I'm not yeah I can't believe you
other tattoo yeah mother effer
I can't what it's offensive though to
some people that's why I can't show it
is the Confederate flag
no dude if I'm going offensive I'm going
Confederate flags a little bit of
laundry bro that's a little bit of pole
laundry Dawg I'm going offensive dude uh
look here's the thing about this tattoo
man I've seen it 2,000 times bro this
goal aiming arm bro Nolan Ryan had that
the old [ __ ] hot arm bro that's
nothing also an eagle on fire you see a
lot of that down south at NASCAR events
you see it's on people's back a lot of
Hell's Angels yeah this seems like
something some little like thought gets
over there in Daytona yeah you right
Daytona 500 standard tattoo yeah this is
a yeah by dr. Wu he thinks all flashy
sometimes I'll leave LA and realize your
tattoos each drives for Riverside and
get your ass beat breaking out that
[ __ ]
squid mistake yeah show up in Ontario
without your Harley with that tattoo see
what the [ __ ] happens yeah you can't
show up on a [ __ ] bird scooter with
that [ __ ] limp piece of Van Gogh on
your wrist bro you have a Harley of some
assless
chaps you go down the [ __ ] Ontario
with that bird tab yeah get this guy out
of my podcaster get the Skyrim podcast
god that was [ __ ] funny though
yeah so the new segments uh no we need
to tell all the new segments sing mate
and we have another one too don't we
yeah we forgot a little pre-production
that we were gonna sag Oh chase my race
my case oh yeah so this is my case so
some other segments that we're gonna do
one is called race my case and that is
where the producers are gonna put
together crimes that have happened and
we have to the four of us have to guess
what race could have done it race my
case will be good so that'll be a new
segment also known as true detective
season for you me - detectives bro true
detective HBO show oh yeah you know it
man
siren yeah a true detectives man your
McConaughey yeah yeah we on a dude you
Woody Harrelson yeah I'm woody here
without the shitty season though with
Vince Vaughn that's not a first season
I'm woody harrelson boy what was the
other one I love that I'm doing crime we
got an hour then you guys take a topic
and argue whether it was better back
then or now cars music sent in by at big
dog on IG yeah we passed on that one but
okay but that's okay I say I think we
can discuss this fully I say next week
we unveil one segment and we'll we'll do
a new one every week but there's people
having wood yeah we can see which one's
sticks routes okay so next week yeah
next week we'll do race my case and
we'll do other named cases yeah so well
that's it for today boys let's you did a
fool that's the episode you guys ran
through that one would not keep debate
club routine enough stay we already I'm
saying you did that how long are we well
over an hour
oh really that's yeah we're at were like
hour five I'd love to get to this
European name yes give me the name one
name game car let's do it Harley
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up what are you
talking and shouting Carly what's up
girl you're so friendly I'm just being
silly
yeah that's true do that
wouldn't quiet I'm joking man you gotta
take that part out
so lime soda was hot Karl and Chris
D'Elia yeah do what your buddy bad it's
your buddy taking over our podcast with
his shitty art whoo dude is that even a
real Asian I've never seen him I heard
about him yeah exactly dude who would
let a fake Asian draw on a big huh
doctor who's big you don't know because
they get a shamrock social club telling
you first of all you barely got out of
the back end of that [ __ ] shamrock
social club yeah and I saw you stare
stepping through it that hopscotch white
rapper friends we got the cats cats
battle rap coming back next week yeah
we're gonna be posting those videos like
we said last time on IG this week we're
gonna get a vote we're gonna have a
winner and we got two two more fire
submissions yeah so like eight a mile up
in this [ __ ] yeah dude like four mile
so from so from time to time we'll be
rolling with some new segments let's do
name game though so people know how to
submit for name game and you don't you
guys don't have to submit for race my
case I don't think could they submit
cases they could they can try but if we
don't find good ones we'll make it up
and say it came from them okay thank you
guys for having me - Veronica go ahead
this is Nick from LA there's another
Nick hey guys this is a nick coming at
you from the La Brea Tower podcast
studio in Hollywood California I got a
little named game submission for you and
in honor of the Rat King returning from
Europe I was wondering if you guys could
name european landmarks thanks for all
the laughs gang gang
buzz buzz there so yeah I can name a few
home tonight okay it's an away game for
your boy huh okay yeah you got their
start yeah start big Ben Roethlisberger
you're out
I'm gonna go with Stonehenge bro
everybody's favorite figurine area bro a
little bit of Stonehenge what's that on
your shirt Oh Stonehenge
well stone stony hanji little stone
handy little stony Hinchcliffe there's
some guy gets up on her show like el
touni and sneeze isn't like all right
that's your time brother you [ __ ] you
did shitty yeah that's your time [ __ ]
hit the drum guys like but I flew here I
took four days off of work
oh you're fired so you're also fired so
I've come every Monday man for the past
[ __ ] three months yeah why pheasant
see me in a month I've been camping
outside
yeah well city first joke your turn
Brendan trying to evade it huh being
landmarks Go Daddy you're pimping let's
go daddy um I feel tower okay um arc de
triomph Wow look at me impressing people
with that Brendan just look cut into
Brendan said where's Niagara Falls you
were just and you are you are crawling
about to lose it uh let me think here
for a second yeah go ahead
what's the giant [ __ ] bridge in
England in London
London London London London can say the
London Bridge hey hey Alex London Bridge
for 3000 count it
boom that's good yeah oh my god that's a
song
London Bridge we're using songs now um
let me thank you landmark yes I got
something good bro I'm not even worried
dude cuz I got the Trevi Fountain
playboy nightclub in Miami balloon Trevi
Fountain in Rome
oh man that's that LM baby that landmark
really surprised there I got one for us
about the Colosseum son Colosseum of
what in Italy bro just checking you dog
no bro second you shoot you gotta know
what's up I know what I'm gonna say man
I'm not some freaking nutcase like you
are dude what I would go with is the
Hamburg Zoo is that a landmark yes it is
they've probably the greatest zoo ever
it's a place yeah but is that a landmark
I don't know man is that like I don't
know if doing any city I say the [ __ ]
wrong zoo Rome zoo is not on there it's
also it's called that it's called the
tier Park Hagen Beck he didn't say that
he didn't say that the hanging man doing
your
European zoo for 3,000 Alex hamburger
out your house bro
do you know what kind of animals they
have there bring up pictures of animals
at the Hamburg zoo it's just French guys
it's just Jewish people it's here Burke
Hawking Beck that Hagen bag yeah you
didn't say he didn't say that tear apart
man look at that elephant bro look at
that toward it looks like your [ __ ]
zoo I've ever seen you're out bro I'm
sorry it's [ __ ]
how about the sixteen Chapel bro this is
Vatican the Vatican what it's what's up
with the Vatican brah
huh what about the 15th chapter alright
now your palaces now you're talkin Romo
but if about the Notre Dom that [ __ ]
gon fire this [ __ ] burn of
course I think went up in fire dude you
get it even though he just got back from
Europe and lost in the name game not a
big deal
I'm still room before you do I'm glad
you came in today for you too man I'm
happy to be here today man thank you so
much for having me dude in your studio
yeah Thank You cat Niki Pascal it's the
year of the rat so I had to let you here
is the route it is boy the rat so all
you [ __ ] know was about all you
guys man
daddy might have to get a tattoo dr. Wu
it's the comeback of the rat son like I
was never gone bruh never gone bro yeah
get on your knees and serve the cheese
baby cuz I'm coming for it son kill me
you tell dirt Lee I'm [ __ ] coming to
get my belt back to you guys gave it to
that [ __ ] pansy everything we let the
fans know you know I mean who are the
fans just you it right kappa we don't
Brian no you know we give out guest of
the year Brian doesn't know anything
Brian looks like Elf on the Shelf - yeah
when he's not working
during the holidays you know like you
need a planet like help on the shelf and
Honey I Shrunk the kids before your
truck it looks like a blood transfusion
on the Shelf doesn't know myself about
rinks on the ship do that that would
sell like hotcakes rink on the show just
have some old dude doll on the shelf
you don't need holidays for that with
someone to Carly what about perv on the
curb there'd be another one dude yeah
said I'm gonna curb somewhere yeah but I
go this tongue like this dude I'll let
you know also on t on this past weekend
we're coming out with crystal e of
voodoo dolls actually put dents in it
yeah she create a big doll you can just
beat the [ __ ] up put a bunch of debt
yeah that's what he just said Brendan no
he said little doll I'm talking I'm I'm
talking like well the ones chinfa real
long sex doll you want this comes in
three part you sure you sure I know it's
on disc out be sure you want the Jay
Leno chin on this one well chin had a
chance at love and you let it pass handy
have any closing remarks
no I hope she has a great future find
someone great well that's weird
your future's not dark yep we got to
help somebody find love man yeah let's
let's think about all of us get together
we're gonna think of a new I think we
still call it gender no matter what
sorry I think the segment's called
gender but me and theory you know
[ __ ] stupid school and I would have
met somebody if it wasn't for you man
[Laughter]
so needs make a graphic of all this in
that [ __ ] skeet van like scooby-doo
hey I got a donate blood at 1:30 here
actually I'm really gonna take your
blood Wow ha ha oh like yeah they come
here and get it what they come here and
take you wait anymore what kind of dark
web donation is this wow it's supposed
to be on the up and up well they have a
website alright man well that's it I'm
in Charlotte this wouldn't we drop in
this this week yeah Thursday night Nick
I'm in Charlotte Thursday Friday
Saturday next week Columbus Ohio baby
yep and I'll be in Denver this weekend
we're on Denver Doug South comedy you
had the landmark south yeah myself just
going to work on some new materials
going there
you don't want to do the downtown one
mm-hmm there's more seats about my papa
lives across the street really literally
across the street from the downtown one
no from South dude bring him over it'd
be cool yeah
be nice to him yeah please don't clown
my dad I would never do that yeah you'd
sock you right in the [ __ ] what are
you really oh yeah the cool yeah be fun
show with black guys don't bring a black
stuff around dad whose bag its hood it's
[ __ ] really
I'll go Jersey shopping with your dad
dude that's what I'm talking about
oh I'm assuming those are sold out but
yeah we got to uh glad we're back man
yeah dude it's good to be back man we
got an exciting year a lot of new
segments new segments new merchandise
the Mertz coming I see for that ass we
got some new artwork everything's good
we're cruising along hot dogs yep can't
found love even though he didn't tell us
he already had it Wow we're SEPA sewed
of The Bachelor ever imagined be done
ABC like this all these people are here
for you man helicopters go to Paris yeah
sorry man I got found so right before I
got here that's what you did to us
I hope you're happy brother
congratulations to Carly hot Karl
yeah Carly we love you
especially me a girl yet where were you
say gang gang buzz-buzz